si un martien débarqué dans l'hémicycle
il se dirait mais les français sont
dingues
au delà de la personnalité de bernard
cazeneuve passé quand même l'homme d'un
échec sidérant
des centaines de morts sur le sol
français
des policiers dans la rue una sécurité
incroyable des frontières pas contrôler
des migrants à qui on donne plus
davantage que des français qui
travaillent 40 l'intérieur mais c'était
le ministre de l'intérieur avec le
gouvernement mais d'un drame national et
tous pour lui un bon train mais il n'a
pas pris les mesures qui s'imposaient
c'est pas lui spécifiquement d'ailleurs
qu'il reste en soi au lendemain il y en
avait beaucoup j'avais proposé 25
mesures notamment d'arrêter les
djihadistes qui revient de syrie et sur
l'attentât de nice il ya beaucoup à dire
mais on n'est plus une démocratie mais
vous ne verriez jamais cela dans un pays
anglo saxon la promotion de l'échec et
tous les autres car ne l'oublions de la
chasse et la promotion de l'échec et
tous les autres qui applaudissent comme
des comme des pantins
mais on est où on vit où on vit dans
quel pays
mais les français à juste titre je le
redis réveillez vous mais revenez sur
terre
il n'y a pas une entreprise ya pas une
association n'y a pas une télévision où
quelqu'un qui a échoué autant sur le
plan de la sécurité pose pour être
premier ministre
enfin ça y est j'y parle mais c'est la
décrédibilisation total de l'action
publique mais la rigueur ce qui est
tragique c'est que les français s'en
fiche complètement puisque c'est pour
quelques semaines